let's explore the API a little bit.
Now, we saw earlier that we could set
the location of the panorama by calling
setPosition on the Street View Panorama
object and give it latitude and
longitude.
In addition to that,
we could also get the location, and
this will return
a StreetViewPanoramaLocation Object.
This object itself will have
a latitude and longitude on it.
So you can use this if the user has
moved around the map to understand
where the user is presently, and then
you can plot that location on a map.
So, for example, if the user was
hiking down the Grand Canyon,
you could have a map beside
the StreetViewPanoramaView, and
as the user moves down the Grand Canyon,
or the user moves along in Street View,
you can have a pin on the map update to
show the user's location based
on what they're looking at.
You can also getPanoramaCamera
on the StreetViewPanorama.
Now you might remember the camera
from earlier in this course, and
the concepts are the same.
This will return
a StreetViewPanoramaCamera
as you saw when we
were creating the app.
And this will allow you to read or
edit things such as the zoom, the tilt,
the bearing, etc.
Let's take a look at the code now and
look at the panorama camera again and
see how we had set it up.
So, if you remember back to the code,
I've changed the camera view
to be one where it points south
by setting the bearing to be 180.
I created a StreetViewPanoramaCamera,
and I tell the panorama to animate
to that camera at this bearing.
I could have done similar
things with tilt or
zoom, just like I would with
the mapping application.
So, if you're not familiar with this,
check back to the sections where we
explored using the camera on a map
view earlier in this course.